In order to analyze how you use your time, create a time log.
A good way would be to divide the day into 15-minute slots.
Note tasks that you do a lot, like writing, emailing, traveling, etc., across the top of the page.
Underneath could be a row where you write down what you actually did.
Three columns entitled "enjoyment," "productivity" and "energy" could be below that.
In the first column, jot down activities that you liked or disliked.
Under "productivity," mark "high" or "low," and the same under the energy column.
Why? Because you can be highly energetic, yet still be very low in productivity, doing something unnecessary.
Alternatively, you could have low energy but be productive.
Do the logs only for a few consecutive days.
Then, consider the following five questions:...
...Do you need to do it?
Can the frequency be changed?
Can the quality be changed?
Can the method be changed?
Can you delegate part or the whole task?